the module design pattern in JavaScript
is one of the most used design patterns
for keeping particular pieces of code
independent from each other modules
allow you to break up different parts of
your code to make it easier to maintain
and reason about also modules can
provide encapsulation which can protect
properties and functions from being
accessed from other parts of the code
before javascript es6 you would set a
module like this you would declare this
function that you would have the private
variables or functions up here and then
you would return what you wanted your
public variables or functions to be and
then it would just be immediately
invoked right here this is just a
closure that returns an object I'm not
going to go into much detail about this
because there is a new way to do it with
es6 the module pattern can be
accomplished using classes this allows
you to keep units of code cleanly
separated and organized so with es6 or
modules will look something like this
now the whole point of modules is that
you're keeping code separated usually in
different files so I don't have
different files on here but this is
representing one file here and this this
time here main digest is representing
another file so let's look through this
we have a class shopping data type and
we have a constructor these are going to
be the private properties this that
shopping list equals coffee chicken
pizza so we're creating an array that
that's a private array now we also have
these public methods get shopping list
where it's not going to return the
actual array it's actually going to
return a string that join is just going
to return a string with all these items
with all the items in the array
separated by a comma and a space so you
cannot have access to the actual array
and then we can also add an item that
function here it's just going to push
the item onto the array so at the end of
the file we have to do this line export
default shopping data type so that's
just going to export this class so we
can use it in a different file at the
beginning of the other file we're going
to put import shopping data type from
libs less module that's just the
directory and file name without the j/s
and after we import that and we can
start using
the file so we can do something like and
this would allow you to print the
shopping list in the other file so this
is just a simple example of a module but
they can be pretty complex and just
allow you to keep code independent from
each other in different files thanks for
watching my name is beau Carnes check
the description for links to more
information don't forget to subscribe
and remember use your code for good